this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
welcome um happy GIS day GIS i guess
most notably is gps things I my GPS unit
despite having traffic references
reliably takes me into the the biggest
traffic messes that can find I guess
that's a feature welcome to EE 380
Stanford computer systems like lab
colloquium fall 2012 2013 I'm Andy
Freeman the other course organizer is
Dennis Allison many ideas take a long
time to catch on take long take online
education this broom and this whole
building is pretty much ideal for online
education it's been used for that since
before the web existed in fact many of
the people had seminal roles in
developing the world wide web either
taught or we're taught in this room and
others like it so the web wasn't
necessary but the title of today's talk
is one night online education one years
later one year later something happened
a year ago that changed how we thought
about online education suddenly became
popular possible and caught on the
tipping point wasn't technology though
although technology had played a role
Peter Norvig who has taught online who's
done online education for a while is
here to discuss how we got here where
we're likely to go and how we and why we
got here right thanks to the great
introduction okay so how did we get here
or how did I get here I guess my Pat
comes through this textbook so I had
been a professor but for the last decade
and a half I had dropped out of that and
it had been in industry but back in in
my dot edu days I did come up with this
textbook and the publisher comes back to
you every few years and says it's time
to update it so I did that with my
co-author Stuart Russell and the the
most recent time I was
really struck more than in the past
about how limiting it is to write
something and stamp it on to dead trees
so here's a section from the book and it
was one that we went sort of back and
forth on Stewart took a crack at writing
it I thought it wasn't quite right and i
wrote a version and so on and then we we
had to publish something and it really
struck me how the two of us were so the
worst qualified people on earth to
decide which version to include because
it had been a long time since we
remember what it was like to learn this
material and really we should be asking
someone who'll be learning it for the
first time not asking ourselves so so
that was bad and it struck me at about
how we were losing this feedback loop
that we published this stuff and it goes
out there and students by the book and
then they take out the yellow marker and
they say oh that part's important and if
they're very organized they have to
color markers and they say that part's
really confusing and then they write in
the margin and so on and we don't get to
see any of that and that's really the
most useful stuff it's not us deciding
oh I think this version is better than
that version it's the students who
should be society that and if we had a
way to close that loop and get this
information back we can make the book a
lot better similarly here's an example
so there's lots of charts and graphs and
all that stuff and in order to generate
this you know I i took some data I wrote
a program then there's a correspondence
between this graph and this
representation of the lost service and I
played around with that and then I
rotated this 3d surface in order to find
a view that I thought was a good view
and I learned a lot by playing with the
program but the student doesn't get to
do any of that they don't the student
doesn't really see this as a 3d surface
in the same way that I did by get it by
manipulating it by looking at different
views by changing the data and seeing
seeing how that goes back and forth and
so on they lose all of that and we'd
like to be able to give them a way to
get that experience back
so Hal Abelson MIT professor has been
doing this stuff for a lot longer than
they're not certainly that I have and
then most people have he was behind the
MIT OpenCourseWare a decade ago and
before that had revolutionized computer
science education and so on and I asked
him how I want to understand the theory
of education what do I need to know and
I expected him you know to give me a
stack of books this high and I'd be in
for a long bout of reading and it turned
out I got the best answer I ever got
which he said you only have to read one
paper and it's this paper by benjamin
bloom in the 1980s of what bloom calls
the to Sigma effect and in bloom studies
if you give students one-on-one tutoring
with what he calls mastery learning
which is the simple idea that you teach
something until the student gets it
rather than teaching it until the day of
the test then the students improve by
two standard deviations so it's this
near Lake Wobegon effect two standard
deviations means ninety-eight percent of
the students are above average now I
should say that not everybody duplicates
this other people who try this don't
quite quite get two standard deviations
but it's striking because most of the
things that you try in education you
have a great idea and you go out and try
it and you can't measure any effect at
all so the fact that there is a market
affect whether it's one standard
deviation or two is really quite telling
so this is really the challenge then
that we know what works if we could
afford to have a great tutor and give
that to every student then we can have
great success but as a society we can't
afford to do that for two reasons there
aren't that many great tutors and
secondly we don't want to pay for it
we're barely willing to pay for one
teacher for thirty students we're not
willing to multiply those costs by 30 so
the the science says it works and the
sort of intuition says it works as well
so I remember
there's a picture of me with my first
tutor going one-on-one and that worked
pretty well so we're trying to think of
how to duplicate that and so Sebastian
throne and I was our turn to teach the
AI class here at Stanford just a year
ago and we said well let's see how close
we can get to that so yes we got to
teach the class in class will do the
sort of the normal thing but will also
offer version online open that up to the
world and see if we can do it in a way
that's not just duplicating the lectures
but is getting as close as we can to
this ideal so we got to work and we
start off trying to have this
conversation as as if it was one-on-one
tutoring but instead of talking to a
live student it was talking to a video
camera but making it look as if you know
this doesn't have to be polished this it
doesn't have to be you know Brian Green
with this million-dollar animation of
the black hole and the string theory and
so on that you see on the PBS specials
it's just sketching on the back of a
napkin we thought that that was a better
way to learn and to approach this
one-on-one so we got to work in our
studies at home we announced the class
that we were going to do this we're
going to open it up to the world
Sebastian says you know we could get
10,000 people doing this nice of a
sebastian euro is a dreamer but we'll
definitely get a couple thousand and
soon enough it was on or 60,000 students
in 209 countries had signed up and and
other people were doing it too so
Sebastian and I were the first to
announce you know they've been lots of
other work a lot of it here at Stanford
Coursera was formed with Daphne Koller
and Andrew Inge and we had known of
their work for a long time I think
Sebastian and I got to go out first
because we were not Stanford professor
employees and so we didn't have to worry
about being fired for bending the rules
a little bit so we got to go out to the
world first but they
been working on stuff internally to
Stanford before we had and deserve a lot
of credit for that so Coursera Udacity
came out of Stanford the ventured labs
and the class to go or all Stanford
efforts a lot of that going on here EDX
out of MIT and Harvard and taken on some
additional university partners as well
at Google we decided we wanted to end to
the game and we launched this class
called power searching with google so
less of an academic class more of a
skill-based we also got up to 150,000
students or so and it has the familiar
format of there's videos and they're
interspersed with we call them
activities so these are things that the
students do that are ungraded and then
they're also tests that are graded and
that works so well we decided well why
we take the technology we had to build
that and open-source it so we did that
we call it course builder and anybody
can download it and build their own
course and that's been out for I think
two months now maybe three months and
we've already got a couple dozen classes
up and running on it from various
universities and nonprofits like sailor
orchid and so on so a lot of interest in
this going on around the world now one
question is we know why now what
happened in the last year that that made
these things take off and i think the
introduction was exactly right that it
really wasn't a technology issue that
these technologies did exist before you
know so nothing is new is not really
advanced technology i guess the the only
thing that's really different is five
years ago when you pressed on a link for
a video you had to cross your fingers a
little bit that you know you weren't
going to get a pop-up that says you need
to install some new plugin now when you
try to play a video it usually plays but
other than that
all the technologies had always been
there and so I I think it's just the
question of waiting for the right moment
waiting for enough people to be
connected where there was a high enough
pool of people who were interested and
maybe waiting for grumbling over the
cost occasion to get high enough that
more people are interested in trying
something new and then also that there
was lots of different inspirations from
different sources and we'll talk about
some of those later now i want to say
what i learned from this about how it
was what i came away with was different
from what I started with and I think to
me the biggest thing I learned was how
important the question of motivation is
now you know I started at at Google in
the search quality team before moving to
research google has this mission
statement of supplying access to all the
world's information and I thought that's
really what my job was was to give
people access to information and to take
the hard questions like the movie in
which no babies are born and in
two-tenths of a second or so come back
with the right answer right so it was
access to information that that's what
our job was but then I started to talk
to some educators and realized it's not
just information so this is a slide from
Teach for America and I remember talking
to a teacher from Teach for America who
was given a math class that was two
years behind a grade level and in one
year the teacher was able to get most
everybody in the class up to grade level
so that showed three years of work in
one year and then I thought well wait a
minute they weren't able to do this
because of information it wasn't like
this year there was a really good
textbook that enabled them to get three
years of work done whereas the year
before the textbook wasn't as good it
was a question of motivation and
determination it was the teacher saying
to the students look we're going to do
this together and I'm going to work
really hard for you I expect you to work
hard for me
and together we're going to make this
work and that's a different way of
looking at it and I realized that at
Google all along we've been doing the
easy part so you know we take this stuff
that you type into the search box and we
come up with an answer and yeah there's
some technology behind that but really
the the educational moment is when you
decide to type something into that box
coming up with the questions more
important than coming up with the answer
and so we started to focus on what can
we do it optimize motivation rather than
information and so what are the keys to
that well one part is willpower is that
it's hard work for these students to do
three years of math and in one year so
how are we going to get them to do that
and in particular how can we do this for
this college class no I mentioned the
MIT OpenCourseWare Hal Abelson showed me
the logs for that you know they've got
all these MIT classes online you can go
and watch the videos at any time and
lots of people watch the first video not
so many the second and then it begins to
fall off and you know the great thing
about the web is that the videos are
there you can watch them anytime but if
you can watch many time you can watch
them tomorrow and if you can watch him
tomorrow well sometimes tomorrow never
comes and so I thought well how did I
make it through college was it because I
had great willpower and as i think back
the answer was no it's because there
were due dates and i started to do my
work because if I didn't I'd be
penalized and I had to get it done by a
certain time and and we can all see this
so Sebastian I saw this in our logs
Daphne Koller told me she sees it in the
Udacity logs that when you look at the
usage on each of these classes yes
there's this exponential decay of people
dropping out but on top of that there's
this sine wave of when the assignments
do people work hard and when it's not do
they don't work as hard so due dates is
important and having peers is also
important and we combine those together
by saying
well the great thing about having due
dates is now if the Simon's due on
Monday everybody's working on the same
thing and when they go into the
discussion forum they get an answer in
five minutes whereas for the MIT
OpenCourseWare where all the lectures
are open all the time your chances of
asking question and having somebody who
knows the answer being working on the
same thing at the same time is low so we
wanted to concentrate this cohorts
together and then we thought why were
these classes successful I think part of
it was was pride you're an early adopter
in a new technology you were able to do
this accomplishment we have the Stanford
name associated with it whereas in the
past there wasn't that much of an
association either was sort of lesser
institutions offering these classes or
with something like MIT where yes you
can see the classes but you aren't you
don't really get any sort of feedback
directly from them so we were offering a
chance to say you've accomplished this
you've done the same thing as a Stanford
student now we had delicate negotiations
with a Stanford administration we
weren't able to give them any
certificate that said Stanford on it it
only said my name and Sebastian's name
on it but students still made that
Association and then I think this idea
of the authenticity of the teacher
saying I'm making a commitment to you
I'm an authority in the field and I want
to share this information with you I'm
going to work for you but I expect you
to work for me so that's part of it I
think another part of it is this idea of
constructivism that as one of my idols
herb Simon who's one of the founders of
my field of AI butts also influential in
learning theory reminds us that learning
is something that the students do do not
something that the teacher does and i
think you know as a university professor
as a text book writer sometimes you get
carried away and saying well the
important thing is for me to say clearly
what i know and if i do that then my job
is done that's not how learning works
when it goes on in students head
in my head so we want to remember that
and we sort of shifted everything around
backwards so we came up with a problem
first and then the explanation and made
the students puzzle things true now one
thing we know from research in education
is if the student has a misconception
giving them the right model doesn't help
they still stick with their
misconception and you know and you can
tell them something and say yeah yeah
that makes sense that makes sense I got
it I got it but that doesn't displace
they're wrong model and then when they
go to solve a problem they get it wrong
the only way to displace it is to
confront them with that so instead of
giving them a good explanation you have
to say okay solve this problem use your
you're wrong model come up with a wrong
answer and then you'll forced to
confront yourself so we made the
students do that we gave him a problem
where we hadn't explained how to do it
yet we made them come up with a
prediction of how it's going to work and
boy they hated that because we have
trained students that the important
thing is not to think not to learn the
important thing is to get all check
marks on all your problems and when we
gave them something that they didn't
know how to get the right answer they
were really annoyed and I think we have
to work better on the messaging for that
to say you're not expected to get this
right it's okay to get it wrong and that
can be done with the right you I I think
we needed to do a better job of it I
would like to have more open-ended
activities not just multiple choice and
fill in the blank we've made some
progress on that we could do a lot
better and programming is probably the
best place where we can do that now
where we you can have the student doing
something that's more open and creative
but still graded automatically if you
can't great it automatically there's
been some experiments with peer grading
and self grading and so on they think
are very promising now another one of my
colleagues Hal Varian talked about his
experience writing this text book on
macroeconomics and he was at bell labs
at the time
and Richard Hamming there told them well
here's how you write a textbook is you
figure out the problems that you want
students to be able to do and then you
write sex book so that they can solve
all the problems and I thought and I
said hey where have I seen this before
well I know this is test driven
development all right so you when you
start a software project you write all
the tests first and then you run the
test suite and you get a red light that
says it fails and only then do you write
code because one of the tests fail and
so when you're you could write a
textbook in the same way you only write
a chapter or section of the test book of
the textbook because one of the tests
failed okay and the next idea is this
idea of individualization and that's
something that I think for all the
excitement about this new round of
courses that have come out none of them
have really addressed this and they're
all taking this linear path and yes
there's individualization of you got it
right or you got it wrong but after you
get it right or wrong then everybody is
the same next problem so in order to get
to these benefits of one-on-one tutoring
we've got to understand better how each
student is different so we did part of
that with this idea of mixed initiative
so Sebastian and I learned from Khan
Academy and compared to say MIT
OpenCourseWare that a five minute video
or ten minute video is better than an
hour long video nobody has the attention
span to listen for an hour especially
when you're on a little screen this big
maybe that's true also for you guys
listening to me so maybe I'm doing this
all wrong i should have involved you in
doing some exercises but that's the
traditional model it's hard for us to
break away from it you know khan arrived
at the 10-minute exercise for the very
important theoretical reason that 10
minutes was the upload limit on youtube
at the time and so that's what he did
and it turned out to be about right we
decided we wanted to go even shorter and
so our average video was about two
minutes
then we would stop and have the student
do something and there's two parts to
that one you you want to just make sure
they aren't sleeping and so even if they
have to answer a trivial question now
they're doing an interaction and
stealing more like one-on-one but also
we wanted them to be doing more of the
work we didn't want to be lecturing
saying okay I'm gonna explain the whole
thing now you figure it out rather we
wanted to say we're looking at a new
area what do you think you try something
that didn't work out we'll say a little
bit more and we'll go from there we'd
like to get to the point where it's a
multi-path not a single path we aren't
there yet different students should be
able to do different things based on
their background based on their current
misconceptions and based on their
interests we learned a little bit from
the flipped classroom that Daphne had
been experimenting with where you watch
the videos offline and then you come
into the classroom and try to do the
discussion we also learned from Eric
Mazur or had this idea of pure
instruction to what I was talking about
at the beginning of you know it's the
students who know best what it's like to
be confused and so they should be the
ones explaining things to each other and
so I think these are all models we could
try to incorporate and they lead into
this idea of socialization that so far
we mostly concentrating on the
interaction between the teacher and the
student but it's really the interactions
between students that are probably more
important and the best we could do for
this was the discussion forum I think
the problem that we're dealing with in
online classes that makes it more
difficult than a stanford class is the
dynamic range of backgrounds and
abilities of the students so i'm used to
you know when i teach at Stanford you
say yeah you got some students that are
really good and some students that are
not so good but the differences may be a
factor of two or three between the best
students and and they're not so good
students because they all got admitted
into Stanford they all took the
prerequisites for the class they all
speak English they all have some set of
backgrounds
so there's not that much difference
between them on the online classes we
saw differences of a factor of 50 rather
than a factor of two or three so very
different backgrounds and trying to keep
those all together it's part of the
challenge so what we really need is a
way that allows for the flexibility but
still has these cohorts all right so you
still want people be able to go and do a
discussion forum and find other people
that are working on the same thing but
you don't want to force everybody to
work at exactly the same speed I think
we need to figure out models you know
it's got to be like you know we ran this
class like a train everybody gets on the
train the beginning of the semester and
then we go and people are dropping out
sort of at each stop along the way we
got to run it like a train schedule
where there's lots of trains leaving the
station and you can go for a while but
then maybe something comes up in your
life you have to drop out for a couple
of weeks but but there's another train
you can catch coming on later and
there's Express trains and slow with
drains and so on now when we ran the AI
class it turned out that they're all
sorts of her sort of social media sites
where students got together in part
because you know I said we were
surprised by the number of people that
signed up and we went back to our
programmers and said you know are you
sure this site's going to hold up with a
hundred thousand students rather than
10,000 students and they said well we're
not quite sure so we cut back on some
features and the forum wasn't quite
ready to go at the start of the class
and turned out that was a great decision
because what it meant is that the
students went to all these other sites
they went to Reddit and Facebook and G+
and everyplace else and they had more of
a sense of identity because they said
rather than just being one forum that
was foisted upon them was like hey you
know we made this forum ourselves we
went out and we started this group and
and it's a smaller more intimate group
and we're having our discussions here
for analytics it was bad because now we
no longer have we haven't captured that
we haven't been able to mark back we you
know we can't say Oh students who
discussed this
times did this well on the final exam we
lost that but we gained this sense of
intimacy of people having small groups
that they created and felt proud about
so not sure about going forward about
how to capture that and then I think one
of the most important parts is this idea
of continual improvement now it may not
be an accident that if you look at some
of the people who are involved in this
recent round of classes from a year ago
you have me and Sebastian Daphne Koller
and Andrew Inge are all have experienced
in machine learning all right so all
people who say you know if we collect a
lot of data maybe we could do something
with this to make education better and I
think part of what we all see but
haven't gotten to yet is this idea that
we got to move away from this model of a
classes a single sequence from one
lesson to another to a model where
there's a flexible environment where
there's many paths through the sequences
and maybe where they aren't all authored
by a single author the way the classes
are done now but where there's a
community of authors of different types
and you can assemble a class by having
the best one from each and so this has
different endpoints yeah that's right as
life does right and so it's it makes
things more complicated right maybe
there isn't such a thing as an
individual class rather there's
different students want different things
they go in different places they learn
in different ways and we should be able
to evaluate for a given student and for
an objective what's the right next thing
to show them and some of that should be
done through analysis and prediction by
the system and some of it should be
open-ended where the students are able
to make those choices what does it mean
then you have taken a class that has
different endpoints yeah that's a good
question so
so that leads into the next thing of
this evaluation model so here's the
traditional transcript right so this is
the result of going to college finding
whatever it is you spend to be here you
get back this portrayal of information
which depending on what you believe
about grade inflation and therefore the
entropy of grades something like a band
width of 20 bits per year which is not
that great compare it to a consumer
product like this which is under ninety
two thousand bits per second so that's
that's a trillion times more bandwidth
and and the cost especially at a place
like Stanford makes it a quadrillion
times higher for dollar so maybe we
could put a little bit more information
in there so maybe it's not just hey you
pass one class and you got an A in this
class and an a-minus in that class maybe
instead what we want is you have a
portfolio and and that's what's
important right so think about you know
yes but I don't do that much hiring of
people straight out of undergraduate so
I don't really look at transcripts I'm
hiring more PhDs but people do do that
they hire people out of school and they
say yeah I want the ones that have a
high grade point average and that works
to some degree because we trust these
institutions and we trust at the grades
mean something but compare that to if I
wanted to hire a piano player or a
sculptor right but if I want a higher
sculptor I don't say hey you know what
you get in sculpting 1010 only an
a-minus geez I don't know maybe I want a
guy who wants it who got the a I'm not
going to do that i'm going to say show
me some sculptures and yeah I like that
one you're good enough for me and so if
we have people who present portfolio
this is what I've done rather than
present a grade point average
that may give us a much better picture
of is this the person I want to do the
next thing to have this job to go on to
this position and so on so I think
that's the opportunity and now you know
sort of the other talk I give about my
work at Google is the Big Data talk
saying we have lots of data for things
like language analysis and image
processing and so on and we have I can
show lots of pictures that have that
look like this where we start out with
data and when we have tens or thousands
of examples our performance is really
crappy and when we have millions or
billions of examples our performance is
really good and I won't be demonstrating
those here but we have lots of examples
and the hope is that education is like
that that if you're only getting this
small number of feedback so hey I got an
A in this class you aren't learning that
much but if I have many interactions per
second and I'm monitoring all that and
seeing what works and what doesn't work
then maybe I can get off to the right
side of up here and get some
improvements in that now so that's the
hopeful message but things don't always
work out so well in in practice it's
been said that education is the
Afghanistan of Technology it's where
promising technologies come in and say
I'm going to be the one to conquer it
and then ten years later they sort of
slink out with their tails between their
legs and that's been true for every one
of these technologies demonstrated here
and the first one this is edison with
eastman 1913 edison said books will soon
be obsolete in the public schools
scholars will be instructed through the
eye as possible to teach every branch of
human knowledge with a motion picture
and our school system will be completely
changed inside of 10 years so that was
true in 1913 and people have been saying
that every decades 10
that we're about to have a revolution
and all these technologies have have
come and gone so now some of these have
something in common so motion pictures
radio television video cassettes these
were all broadcast media so these were
all taking stuff sort of out of the
teachers head and trying to put them
into the students head in a slightly
different way but they didn't have any
notion of interaction now the personal
computer started having a little bit of
interaction but you know as 80s model
computer and the types of interaction we
had their didn't really close the
feedback loop as much I think now we
have maybe the first time to have a
really good opportunity to gather a lot
of data coming back as well as going out
and hopefully that will allow us to make
more rapid improvement so in conclusion
you know to have good pedagogical
practice we were supposed to sum up one
on one seems to be the best way to teach
rather than to lecture so let's try to
do that in a cost-effective way maybe we
can do this a hundred thousand at a time
but if we're going to do that it's not
going to be the one to a hundred
thousand it's going to be the
peer-to-peer and so all pairs of these
hundred thousands interacting with each
other I think is more powerful than than
trying to do the broadcast approach okay
so when we stop there and open it up for
questions test student development
sounds an awful lot like teach to the
test and we know that's evil comments
yeah okay I guess you you want to teach
to the to the right test or to the right
goals so you what you want to say what
is it that I want my students to be able
to do and if that's a list of specific
skill
those are specific questions then you
end up teaching to that but if it's a
list of attributes of you know I want
them to be able to deal with novel
problems and work on them effectively I
don't see anything wrong with teaching
to that test that actually one problem
the strikes me is in all tending towards
these assessment tools is the feedback
loop tends to be far too short in the
assessment what are here's what your
thoughts are in terms of getting you
know maybe multiple years down the road
or farther and that yeah I'm not sure I
got all that question but uh there's
certainly some of it that resonates with
me and I think you're right about the
feedback loop being short and I think
that part of the problem is that that
students are really good at sort of
pattern matching and getting the right
answer right so it's actually talking
earlier today with the some people at
Khan Academy and they say oh you know we
give them these random problems and we
want to teach them things like you know
X to the zeroth power is one and they
learn to do it will give them examples
of that and while we're giving them
examples they sort of learn that and
during that ten minutes they're working
on the examples they figure it out and
they say okay every time I get something
with a zero in the exponent I know what
to do but then a week later when they
have to apply that in some real
situation they forgotten it and so I
think we we need to do two things one is
it's not that learning is binary and
you've learned a skill or you haven't so
we need to not just check it off and say
we're done we need to revisit it and
figure out what's the right schedule for
coming back and verifying that you've
done something before we want to be able
to do it in a way that's in a
rusev right so if I'm showing you a
arithmetic or a math problem that you've
seen before and it's trivial for you
then you get annoyed but if I can do it
in some way that I give you a more
complex problem and I know the only way
for you to solve it is to combine these
three pieces then I can check you off
and say yes you've got this piece that
you got from a couple weeks ago I know
you have it because it's a component of
this solution without bothering you with
a trivial part so we need to build our
our interactions in such a way that we
understand what we're testing poor and
then retest for them and so I think is
this combination of revisiting but doing
it in a more natural setting rather than
in this sort of quiz like setting my /
supplied by saying the essence is teach
students teaching students that's the
new one on one I think that's part of it
part of it is students interacting with
environments in which they're you know
dealing with simulations and so on part
of it is getting away from the lecture
and having interaction of the students
with the instructional system so you
don't don't tell them ask them and I
think these are all components for
returning to Benjamin bloom from loan on
curious about the prospects for true
automated tutoring and foresee any
domain that's narrow enough and an
interaction channel that's ample enough
in which you could imagine fully
automated system being comparable to the
performance of a human tutor yeah so
that's you know but the arenal bloom
code is from the 80's and there and
there was work particularly at carnegie
going back to the 80's of building these
expert systems that there were some work
here with patrick soups and in very
limited domains they seemed to do okay
you know sort of the
the reviews are mixed so if you look at
this this Carnegie learning they say
they do a good job but some of the
independent evaluations say well I see
no effect and they say then say well
that's because the teachers weren't
trained and and how to use the system so
we're not quite sure how well they work
but I think they could be made to work
and and yes you know you have a limited
domain you know teaching kids
subtraction and you can go through and
you can have a catalog of bugs and say
you know here's they forgot to carry and
we can diagnose that and then we can
come up with good interventions so I
think that can be done and it probably
worth doing four subjects that we want
to teach to a lot of students that are
basic like that for but we can't do that
for every subject because knowledge
engineering for that it's a lot of work
so I think one of the questions is can
some of that emerge automatically so
rather than having a an expert teacher
sit down and say you know these are the
20 bugs that people have in trying to do
subtraction can we have a learning
system say all right you know we just
defined one path without trying to
identify the bugs but hey here's a
pattern a lot of students miss problems
317 and 42 together and and they
continue to miss those until we show
them this video and then they start
getting it right and so if we can find
those sorts of patterns then we can do
the right intervention and then maybe
you show it to a human analyst to say
hey something's going on here with this
pattern what do you think and then the
analyst says oh I see that's a
forgetting to carry problem and then
maybe you you add some more to fix that
up I think we just don't know yet if
whether we can gather enough data to to
do that type of analysis that's it you
build a toilet laws pretty much anyone
who wants to build a course builder
coercion but seeing we should make
videos dealing the through some very
by that whatever Mason a present it's
actually valid and don't have someone
who doesn't know what they're doing yeah
instead of doing good actually creating
it more problems yes so that's true for
online learning it is also true for
offline learning that there's always
going to be teachers who say the wrong
thing and and you've seen a bunch of
criticisms recently of khan of sebastian
throne and so on people saying oh here's
some place but they didn't do quite the
right thing I think it's good that
there's a marketplace to fix that type
of stuff and you've seen vast reaction
to these criticisms certainly much
faster than you get in textbooks when a
textbook is wrong you know it's a couple
years cycle before the corrections come
out rather than the online stuff it can
be much more rapid I think we'll see
more progress when we can break down the
units smaller so rather than saying I'm
going to take a class here say I'm going
to take a path through a bunch of
materials and maybe that path is
assembled from the best of lots of
different authors I think that can be
done is a little bit tricky you know
there are things like just style other
things like terminology and notation
that varies from one author to another
and so you don't want to be inconsistent
but I'm hopeful that there's a way of
doing that and we can choose the best of
each and we can correct the ones that
are that are wrong now that you know
everybody wants to compare to Wikipedia
right to say I know can tell you how
many times I've heard people pitch
saying what we're going to be the
Wikipedia of X so the Wikipedia of
Education I think part of it is that
it's just more effort to put together a
class than it is to to contribute to
Wikipedia and and there's two types of
contributors to Wikipedia some people go
in and added a single sentence saying
there was a grammar mistake here or they
missed one fact that I have
to know and so that's a nice
contribution that you can make and we
don't have equivalent of that yet in the
class setting you can't just make one
small change I think we want to build
systems where you can do that you have
to verify that the change is right but
you want to be able to do that but then
the other contribution you can make to
Wikipedia is writing a whole page but
even that is much less work than
creating a full course so we can't just
say if we build something that's like
Wikipedia it's all of a sudden going to
be filled up with courses we need a
different incentive and structure and in
order to make people put in much more
work than they did in wikipedia and and
is getting that was incentives right
gonna be tricky so seeing a lot of
really create online open courses for
college level material I haven't heard
about as many for sort of middle school
high school level is that assembling
bias is that just because Khan Academy
is so good that I haven't tried or is
there some other reasons that I think
there's a lot of reasons it's so so Khan
does a good job of it I think that this
probably thought that there's a an
easier financial path in the university
level it may be that university
professors have more free time than than
k-12 teachers computer expertise sir
it's certainly part of it and you know
particularly in the US I think you know
if you're a startup company you're a
little bit put off by the prospects of
saying okay well I'm going to put out a
product for k-12 and then I'm going to
fight school district by school district
all the way across the country and
that's just daunting and it's easier to
say well put this stuff out there at the
university level and I
and get huge adoption without having to
make those types of fights now that you
can go to pass you can try to be
integrated into the classroom in which
you have to solve all those political
problems or you can be augmentation
outside of the classroom and and
certainly there are some of those
there's several startups that are
attacking the k-12 space as mostly as
this augmentation I think you'll
probably see more going on in other
countries where you you know where you
can go to a central government and get
pick up a whole country at a time rather
than trying to go district by district
the way you have to in the US what are
the prospects for getting credentials or
course credit or even degrees based on
this kind of learning yeah that's a
great question and so you know the
current round is really focused on
saying you don't get anything official
you know you get a PDF document with the
signature on it is that worth anything
well I've definitely had students come
up to me and say well I got my job
because I took your class and I don't
know how true that is whether they would
have gotten the job anyways but it seems
like it's worth something but it's
definitely worth much less than an
official degree and so what are the
routes well one is you can say well it's
just fine the way it is that if you have
the skill that's what matters and you
can be evaluated separately from
learning the skill another would be to
say well you can learn this stuff and
then go to traditional University and
get accreditation through them and then
a third way would be that there'll be
these new Institute's that are maybe
online focused that will be granting
certificates and then people have to
decide is that as valuable as a real
University certificate or not and and I
don't know how the politics is going to
play out on that I i guess i should say
that one more issue is it's more of a
problem with
the verification of cheating in the
online environment than it is in the
classroom you know you don't really know
you can say this this account got an A
in this class it's hard to really
associate does that account really
correspond to this human being and was
that human being getting some help from
outside or not that's harder to do
online than it is in the classroom I
have a more fantasy question it's got to
do it a lot of courses has got to do
with the mechanics of doing something
where it says what is doable that is a
lot of hats isn't it about how to change
the aspects of education that's knowing
what is doable to put things together
and then have the mechanics so many are
complete a warrior diet aha ok I'm not
sure teaching people how exactly this
long push up the future direction is
that helpful I'm season-worst this
hugging them these are the class of
things that can be solemn music so you
teach them in his high level
capabilities optus science and let them
create something yeah so I guess that's
true it i guess that's that's
independent of the delivery mechanism
whether it's online or classroom or
reading from books or anything else I
think it's we do want to to say to
students it is less important that you
memorize everything then it's more
important that you are able to act in
the world that when you're presented
with a problem that you can figure out
what to do next and what to do next
might be drawing on what you've already
memorized or it might be going and
refreshing what you know or it might be
learning something brand-new in order to
solve the problem so so I think it you
know another aspect that we haven't
talked about as much is the idea of
continuing education and just in time
education that you know it seems silly
to say we're going to have this
four-year period where you're in college
and you learn stuff and then you're done
we know that that doesn't really apply
to the real world and the online
approach seems better suited to this
model of well you're always going to be
learning and you're always faced with a
new challenge something else you have to
learn and it's probably inconvenient for
you to then go and register for a class
and find a college campus and go into a
classroom or rather you want to be able
to do that more on your own and and
having these materials available online
just when you need them seems more
suited to that type of lifelong learning
he mentioned that the you collected a
lot of data from seeing how it is online
learning is happening and have you found
find any particular like real-time data
that you can actually if you knew that
that you could act upon are within that
course and then how can you put the
polygons that occasion yeah so you know
I mentioned collecting the data as being
promising but but I gotta say that what
we've been able to get from it so far it
hasn't been all that interesting in ten
two thousand you're right but it but
it's not so much that we don't have
enough data it's that we don't have the
right data yet just because the types of
interactions that we were doing aren't
as rich as we wanted them to be right
and so I think the main problem was
everybody in the class was following the
exact same sequence and it was only a
question of you know did they get this
problem right or wrong regardless of
what they did they would still go to the
next step this time so you know
we didn't we didn't we don't have an
environmental framework we didn't have
to say okay half students are going to
get a half the students get B now we can
compare which one did better that
wouldn't be so hard to do but we haven't
done it yet and so the data we have is
just not as useful as if there were
those types of interventions yeah this
question of craftsmen field developing a
craft or metrics what are some good
experiments do you think will will you
know come for for how good people when
you talked about transfer how did this
material used for for the purposes it
was designed for like that it seems like
exciting stuff and actually possible you
can know being in Google you can
actually get ya so you you won't be able
to evaluate them so we one of the things
we did do was we ran this searching
class and then we can check afterwards
to say you know deuce do people search
more and do they do better and we can
say yes they do and so you know it does
have an effect yeah because you track
these people there actor yeah so we we
have their their logins and we can go
see how many times they do that and then
we anonymize all that data and keep it
private and so on so we're able to do
this in a way that that outside people
can't and so we see an increase in
ineffectiveness and so we can evaluate
how well this class does and you can
imagine other types of tests of saying
you take the class then you put them in
a real-life situation how well do they
do so so I think there is the
opportunity to to measure that and then
we can see if we can feed that back and
make things better
there's been a lot of you know progress
we made such a big open opening up who
can educate you can see it we're really
excited about that then a lot of your
talk was about how excited you are to
get the data for the things you can
drive find that and you just said you
know you're not sharing that data you
think you get equivalent kind of gains
if you figured out ways to make it more
open than other people could mix and
ideas that you maybe hadn't bought it
yeah so we're definitely interested in
that and and we're thinking about trying
to say well what's the right way to
share data and what my camp can be
shared and and part of this ties in to
the question of why it's harder to do
k12 and the ants part of the answer is
there's more rules about how you have to
treat that data as being confidential
and there's a there's a certain level of
aggregate data that's easy to to share
right so the you know the local school
systems all share their mean scores on
these standardized tests and that seems
fine nobody worries that that's breaking
students confidentiality and so this
aggregate stuff is easy but if you
really want to do the analysis you want
more fine grain and figuring out the
right models for how the student and the
entity runs of the class can agree to
share that in a way that will be
acceptable to both of them without
compromising confidentiality is
something to be worked out
we done well all right thank you
you